hi my name is andres side and he is
arturo gonzález of the house team
street in mexico coste is an application
to help small businesses
recovering data from social networks
integrating them with google up in game
to generate a statistical report
about customers
astrid also helps us to know the
insights that the brand has with its
consumers build is a
tool that allows you to locate
the area where your customers are
through the use and analysis of networks
We give you some graphs and in
a plane the point where are the
target customers through this
we reduce the risk of losses and
We increase your profits, because fruit is
the best option and the best ally of a
trade to locate their customers
effective
Y